I saw Dr. Jen say in her Facebook group the other day that people with active cancer should
it take glutathione or an acetylocyste, both of which I muscle tested for and have been
taking before and after my surgeries, why would she think that she didn't qualify and say
during chemo, which I've heard from conventional docs.
Well, I think we've covered this a lot of times and I cover this in my book, but I'm going
to go over it again, glutathione, what is glutathione, glutathione is your made into a cellular
antioxidant.
What's acetylocyste, acetylocyste is simply a precursor for glutathione, glutathione is recycled
in the cell, glutathione is present in the weight of code, glutathione is present in the cell
cytoplasm.
Glutathione is a made cellular antioxidant, what's that mean?
When you have oxidizing agents come in the cell, this dispersion stuff, it gets rid of them
and reduces them so that they're not this dangerous oxidizing agent because an oxidizing agent
can be damaging to a cell.
So oxidizing agents are toxins, okay, poisons, oxidizing agents can cause cancer, oxidizing
agents can reduce, can oxidize further to peroxidite trait, which can be very damaging to cells.
A damaged cell membranes can damage mitochondria, can damage the nucleus, can be a cause of cancer.
Well, then why wouldn't we want everybody to take a bunch of antioxidants?
So, why wouldn't we?
Well, because cancer cells are already rapidly replicating, and they're rapidly replicating
a far inferior quality cell, and one of the inferior qualities of a cancer cell is that
it has incomplete mitochondria.
So a cancer cell has incomplete mitochondria, cancer cells don't have good glutathione production,
and a cancer cell that is more susceptible to oxidation and death by oxidizing agents.
That's why chemotherapy, when you give chemotherapy to a cancer patient, it can kill the cancer.
Well, chemotherapy can kill healthy cells, too.
Yes, because chemotherapy is an oxidizing agent, and chemotherapy can be a cause of cancer.
Well, then why wouldn't I take it?
Because cancer cells don't produce as much glutathione and cancer cells are more susceptible to oxidation
and deaths by oxidation than healthy cells.
So one theory is that if you give a cancer patient glutathione or an acetylcystine, you could
actually be helping their cancer stay alive because you're helping the cancer survive an
oxidative process.
So I wrote about that in my book, 12 years ago, when I first published it, 15 years ago
or whatever, I still hold fast to that, unless what I tested with muscle testing, that it tests
that they need it.
So I know there's alternative doctors that go, no, everybody should be out glutathione and
acetylcystine, period, whether they have cancer or not.
I just don't agree with what you say, everybody shouldn't be on something, period.
Of course, there's some things that are, you know, everybody shouldn't be as much sugar
and everybody, you know, cancer patients should watch how much they shouldn't be taking glutamine
nutrients, you know, but some cancer patients do well with glutathione and acetylcystine,
some don't.
So only a small percentage of my patients are doing it in glutathione, just so you don't.
So I agree with Dr. Jed to a point.
So I agree with the general statement, but everybody's unique also.
So also just that side note on glutathione and acetylcystine for those who don't have cancer should
everybody be taking glutathione and acetylcystine.
You could argue that it is good because we're exposed to such a high quantity of oxidizing
agents.
However, you have to remember that the oxidation process in your body happens naturally.
You are naturally creating reactive oxygen species within the cell.
It has a purpose.
Remember, nothing is all good or all bad when you talk about physiology.
You have to have a balance of good oxidation and good into oxidation, take you place all
the time.
What's the purpose of your body creating reactive oxygen species?
There it is.
Poisons.
Your body's creating these reactive oxygen species for a purpose.
That's how you kill pathogens.
So another way you kill pathogens is through the creation of reactive oxygen species.
So that's how you can kill intracellular pathogens.
So you have to remember, you have to have a balance, a little balance.
I would agree that we're exposed to poisons on a daily basis that our ancestors would
ever expose to.
So supporting the recycling of glutathione can be helpful.
But with cancer, you have to be even more careful of how much you do sick work.